oh mein gott ok hoffentlich networking
[Gelächter]
herzlich kommen wieder leute ich habe
neben mir max und dave und wir wären
heute zusammen eine ganz besondere
change machen und zwar werden wir jetzt
von unserem gamer hinunter und sitzt auf
der maur jacobs fragen gestellt bekommen
und derjenige der mit seiner antwort auf
die schätzfrage am weitesten entfernt
liegt wird dann vom game master werden
wir alle die augen zu haben im pool
versenkt laut jetzt denkt euch ja
entspannt der pool schilliger urlaub
nein es ist wirklich mittlerweile kalt
ich glaube es ist jetzt gerade hier so
16 grad oder so und der pool ist
arschkalt wirklich es ist so krass dass
max um dave wirklich überzeugt werden
mussten um hierhin zu machen weil es
einfach so unangenehm ist so ist prinzip
leute wie gesagt die antwort machen die
augen zu jacob pins aus und wir fangen
mit der ersten frage
wir machen es mit den antworten übrigens
jetzt dass wir die in unserer whatsapp
gruppe die wir hier mit dem trip haben
reinschreiben jakob es auch darin sich
dann die antworten und werden den
verlierer aus als auf dem weg nach
italien fährt man über die autostrada
del sol unter anderem fährt man da so
durch rom und so das ist eine ganz
bekannte autobahn in italien wie lang
ist diese autostrada del sole denkt
daran wir müssen von drei runterzählen
und alle drei gleichzeitig die gleiche
design das ist wirklich also sollte ich
muss euch noch mal klar machen dieser
pool ist wirklichkeit es ist wirklich
nicht angenehm wir legen jetzt natürlich
genau unsere handy weg geschickt haben
und dann geht es los 123
wir haben die antworten bekommt 1000
kilometer der ist 1100 6100 muss 543 ja
komm einfach mal wieso machen nicht so
dass bin ich da kann man sich ja
oh mein gott wie lange weiter im 100
die meisten wissen wieviele einkerbungen
so schon so kalt also keinen bock auf
die zahl von den bundesstaat michigan
waren einfach schneller schnellen
einsatz von michigan ich habe auch
keinen kalt 324 millionen 22 millionen
320 millionen 21 millionen das heißt am
extrem ende sind einmal mond einmal max
ich hab verloren
[Gelächter]
wieso die leute leute dann glaube ich
glauben halt der in der bundesligasaison
2009/10 2020 und ja er natürlich viel zu
hoch geschossen ja wie viele tore im
durchschnitt pro spiel geschaut 2009/10
2002 ja wie viele tausend buch spiel
durchschnittlich gefallen ok ich muss
natürlich auch sommer zu haben sein
alles okay alles da ich muss kurz an
alle spiele denken ich geschaut hat
fertig 321 doppel schubser vielleicht
oma einen gott max und ich sie dann
beide 28 leute mo 3 kommt 2,9 aber über
3,2 toren kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir nicht
kostenträger war der fall
ich würde das einen träger in ringenberg
machen ich habe angst dass mir mein
weitermachen
es ist für zirka meglio jakob genießt
das auf sonne
er will muss jetzt so ich will auch so
gerne an jakob stelle
[Applaus]
wo vielleicht so wir bleiben die nächste
frage wie viele tore und in derselben
saison bei den frauen geschossen
durchschnittlich pro spiel okay okay war
das 32 1 grad der 4,16
ich glaube dass die unterschiede bei den
frauen so groß sind dass manche teams
unendlich viele tore machen und dass die
deswegen einfach 3,2 wohlig 2,41 wir
waren einfach die kräfte
alte der 43 schon wieder am ehesten die
haltung jakob hat gesagt ich kann nur
soviel sagen bei den eurobonds mehr
sollte wird das wasser ist so kalt ist
kein spaß aber ausgleichen gerechtigkeit
alle waren einmal drin immerhin hast
immer einen dort nichts frage wie viele
einwohner hat das bundesland sachsen
anhalt war okay ich bin ok wat okay okay
okay
hahaha ich bin die ganze zeit am ende
noch mein er ist auch denke ich auch 321
let's go co2 will es könnte ein auch
sein das zu schwer sind 2,2
frage jetzt geht stellen wir lieben es
alle wir denken dass kiosk wie viele
kioske gibt es in deutschland mit lippen
programm
okay wie viele kiosk in deutschland ja
ok alles klar
in berlin sind dass er allein schon die
millionärin 321 o mine verkauft oder
nicht weiß ich dass nach 2003 2005 und
30.000 ja ok
heute geht der badener 2026 4300
20.000 da also alle rein aber ganz
weitesten falsches einer freundin in
einer grünen badehose leute falsche
werte ehrenvoll und jungs die mit dabei
waren heute sind in der beschreibung
verlinkt
zuerst das tut